now you posted a photo from your prom
night look at the hair on you this is
incredible incredible locks yeah on a
young Nick Kroll and I'm curious how was
that prom night did you have a
satisfying prom night it was not great
it was not a great prom what happened my
friend said I was I had like a pre
cocktail party thing for all the kids in
my grade to come to my house and none of
my friends came and then we did the prom
itself was fine and then we went and saw
jazz in New York City then I thought it
was so cool and all of my friends did
not like it was not a cool - what was
your prom did you have a good prom no I
didn't go to prom I it's a long story
but I ended up not going to prom and I
ended up going to a I went to a store
that sold potted plants and fertilizer
cuz my dad needed fertilizer so I ended
up loading a bunch of bags of fertilizer
into the back of a really crappy station
wagon getting covered in fertilizer dust
because he wanted me to plant these
shrubs in the backyard and then I was
driving down route 9 back to my house
and I stopped at a stoplight and next to
me was a limousine and the window
lowered and it was this girl I really
liked and this guy was taking her out
and I was waving to them it's a long
story but I did not go to prom and I
reread a shitty prom fertilizer you know
we didn't you need you didn't need to
say fertilizer you know I'm gonna get in
close I'm gonna get in real close I
can't because of my allergic walnut now
listen you speak with the youth of
America through day you do you do and
you've been at rooms everywhere you've
been asked to stop yeah well my question
is what do you what do you think is I
mean so many young people so many 17 and
18 year olds are gonna miss their prom
this year what do you think how they
gonna get through that well I mean I'm I
think we're I'm working on I'm working
on something actually to try to get to
figure help kids who are missing their
prom
I'm working on something right now for
real but I think like here's what I'll
say it's like whether you get your prom
or not and all these poor seniors who
are socially distance from each other in
their like senior spring it's a
highlight of like high school and of
your childhood before you all go off it
sucks you're not allowed to be around
each other we have to take this very
seriously but I will say like when this
ends and everybody is allowed to
regather it's gonna be a fast
Coenen and I think like all those kids
who are pent up at home they're gonna
get together and they are gonna get I
gotta say I've never been to a fest
great it's like driving a station wagon
full of fertilizer ah Wow okay okay I
missed out on that man fantastic yeah
but I am I will report back but I'm
trying to work on something for for prom
yeah but I will say like it sucks
there's no there's no denying and it
sucks for these kids but I think when we
all get back together those kids are
going to have a good time